"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-François Soudan,
Barack Obama,
qui a des origines africaines,
kényanes, plus précisément,
a dit un jour,
quand il était
président des Etats-Unis :
"L'Afrique, elle n'a pas besoin
d'hommes forts,
"mais d'institutions solides."
Il a raison ?
-Oui, il a dit ça.
C'était une tournée.
Il était au Ghana,
je me souviens, à Accra.
Il a fait
cette fameuse phrase,
reprise beaucoup après.
Je pense qu'il a tort.
-Ah.
-Parce que les deux,
mon général.
Pour créer des institutions fortes,
il faut des hommes forts.
Etablir des institutions
démocratiques fortes sur le papier,
on a vu ce que ça a donné.
Après les conférences de La Baule,
au moment des démocratisations...
-Dans les années 90.
-Oui.
-Début des années 2000,
des institutions démocratiques
ont été remises en place
après l'époque des partis uniques.
Très souvent, il y a eu
des restaurations autoritaires après
parce que les hommes forts,
capables de mener
et d'installer ces institutions
- je parle par exemple
de la justice,
qui est quelque chose
de très important -,
n'étaient pas sur le terrain,
étaient eux-mêmes soumis
en permanence
à des remises en cause électorales.
Donc, il faut les deux.
Il faut les deux
comme il y a deux jambes.
Après, on se passera
des hommes forts,
mais on n'y est pas,
sur le continent.
On en est encore...
-Aux hommes forts ?
-Oui,
et parfois à l'établissement
d'institutions fortes
par ces hommes forts.
-A quel endroit,
par exemple ?
Il y a un exemple
sur le continent ?
-Je pense par exemple
au cas du Rwanda.
-Paul Kagame, donc,
qui est le président
du Rwanda
et qui a installé
des institutions solides ?
-Il a installé,
au niveau de...
L'état de droit, c'est autre chose.
Parlons du droit économique.
-On le voit, là, Paul Kagame.
-Oui. Parlons du droit économique
et du droit des affaires.
Parlons de la possibilité
d'investir pour les étrangers.
Parlons aussi
- c'est l'établissement
d'institutions fortes -,
de l'école,
la formation scolaire.
Parlons aussi de la santé.
Tout ça fait partie
des institutions fortes.
Lui, il l'a fait,
et de manière absolument claire.
Maintenant, c'est un homme fort.
-Oui.
Justement, tout ce que vous dites
sur la santé, l'éducation,
on dit que c'est la "Suisse",
aujourd'hui, de l'Afrique.
Donc c'est montré
en exemple aussi.
-Pour ses résultats
économiques et sociaux
qui sont tout simplement
incontournables.
Vous allez à Kigali,
c'est une autre Afrique.
C'est la ville la plus écologique
du continent.
C'est l'une
des deux ou trois capitales
les plus sûres au monde.
Mais c'est vrai
que c'est un régime
qui a mis
le développement économique
devant le développement
démocratique.
-Et ça...
-C'est extrêmement difficile
de mener les deux de pair,
les deux de front.
C'est très difficile.
-Oui.
-Très peu de gens
y sont parvenus.
On prend le cas, par exemple,
de la Tunisie de Ben Ali,
Quand le décalage est trop fort
entre le développement économique,
- qui était une réussite
à la fin de Ben Ali -,
et le développement
démocratique,
il peut y avoir
ce qui est arrivé :
une révolution.
Il faut faire attention
à ce que l'un ne s'éloigne pas trop
de l'autre,
mais c'est vrai
que le fondement de la démocratie,
c'est aussi l'éducation,
c'est aussi la santé,
c'est aussi
le développement humain,
c'est aussi la mortalité infantile,
toutes ces choses-là.
-L'espérance de vie.
-Et puis l'éducation.
C'est absolument capital.
-Vous qui connaissez
parfaitement l'Afrique,
Il y a un exemple qui correspond
un peu à ce que vous dites.
Sur le développement,
on pourra peut-être y revenir.
C'est le Sénégal.
Il y a eu un pari qui a été fait
sur l'éducation.
Le tiers du budget sénégalais
est consacré à l'éducation
des jeunes.
-Depuis toujours, oui.
-Depuis toujours.
Depuis Senghor.
Il avait mis l'accent là-dessus.
Et la démocratie :
depuis 74, démocratique tripartite,
et après, démocratie
qui s'est ouverte,
avec, somme toute,
cahin-caha,
des alternances à chaque fois.
Le Sénégal a marché, là-dessus.
-Oui.
Le Sénégal est un peu
la vitrine, d'ailleurs,
de la partie francophone
de l'Afrique,
mise en valeur, ici, en France, etc.
C'est une véritable démocratie.
Il y a un respect, en général,
des droits de l'homme,
de la liberté d'expression,
de la presse, etc.,
qu'on ne retrouve pas
forcément ailleurs.
C'est aussi un pays
qui a ses propres tensions.
On s'oriente
vers des élections présidentielles
en 2023.
On ignore
si le président Macky Sall
a décidé ou non de s'y représenter.
Il laisse planer une ambiguïté.
Mon opinion, c'est que
s'il a la possibilité
d'y aller, il ira.
Mais ça se passera
de manière
sans doute assez compliquée.
-Vous mettez le doigt
sur quelque chose
qui se passe en Afrique,
pas uniquement
au Sénégal.
Mais on attend de voir,
car on n'en sait rien.
C'est ce qu'on appelle,
dans le jargon africaniste,
les "troisièmistes",
c'est-à-dire
les présidents qui veulent,
eh bien, finalement,
violer la Constitution
ou l'esprit de cette Constitution
ou leur propre parole,
en disant qu'ils feraient
un troisième mandat,
ce qui déplaît considérablement
à la société, généralement.
On a cette tendance,
en Afrique,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un recul,
un peu, de la démocratie.
-Ce qui déplaît, oui,
à une partie de la société,
et à nous,
qui sommes des Occidentaux
et qui regardons cela.
-Oui.
-Ce qui ne déplaît pas forcément
à une autre partie
de la société.
C'est évident qu'un 3e mandat,
il vaut mieux l'éviter.
Mais quelqu'un comme Kagame
ou d'autres vous expliqueront
qu'après tout,
c'est "à la population de décider".
Si elle veut un 3e
ou un 4e mandat,
c'est à elle de le dire.
On peut suivre
ce type de raisonnements,
à condition que les élections
soient réellement
libres et transparentes,
ce qui est,
assez souvent, peu le cas.
-Oui.
-Bon.
Mais le fétichisme
du troisième mandat,
à mon avis,
doit être soumis
à ce genre de réflexions.
Ca n'est pas quelque chose
qui est absolument obligatoire,
de s'arrêter
au bout du deuxième mandat.
On peut avoir envie
de continuer son travail,
à condition qu'on le fasse bien,
qu'on soit redevable
et que cette redevabilité
soit explorée dans les urnes
et validée par les urnes
dans le cadre
d'élections transparentes.
Je ne suis pas un fétichiste :
"2 mandats, 10 ans, ça suffit,
"tu dois partir."
Non, je ne pense pas.
-Ceux qui essayent de pousser
le bouchon un peu plus loin disent :
"C'est moi ou le chaos."
C'est la phrase, d'ailleurs,
que de Gaulle
avait dite
à propos de l'Afrique.
-Ca, c'est la dérive de personnes
qui se sentent indispensables
et qui ne veulent pas partir.
Il y a aussi la dérive
de chefs d'Etat
à durée indéterminée,
qui restent jusqu'à leur mort.
Ils ne veulent pas partir,
pourquoi ?
Souvent,
parce que céder le pouvoir,
à quelqu'un qui a été,
par exemple, votre dauphin,
que vous avez fabriqué...
Souvent, ça se retourne contre vous.
On le voit en Mauritanie,
actuellement,
avec l'ancien président
qui a mis son dauphin
qui, lui, a respecté
la règle des trois mandats.
Il a propulsé son dauphin.
Le problème,
c'est que son dauphin,
dès qu'il arrive au pouvoir,
la première chose qu'il fait,
c'est asseoir sa légitimité
en s'en prenant
à celui qui l'a fait roi.
Souvent, un chef d'Etat
qui laisse le pouvoir,
il ne supporte pas longtemps
l'indépendance de son successeur,
qu'il a fabriqué.
Il veut être consulté,
prendre des décisions
ou être quelqu'un
qui est toujours dans le jeu.
Donc ça se passe très mal.
On l'a vu aussi en Angola
avec... dos Santos.
-Qui a gouverné longtemps.
-Et Lourenço, l'actuel.
Il s'en est pris
à la famille de dos Santos
pour des raisons...
-De son prédécesseur.
-Oui.
-Qu'il accusait de corruption.
-La famille,
corruption, enrichissement.
Tout ça n'était pas faux.
Mais bon, ceux qui sont
actuellement au pouvoir,
et qui y sont encore,
ils voient ça
et y réfléchissent
plutôt à deux fois
avant de se dire :
"Je nomme un dauphin
qui me foutra la paix
"à moi, ma famille
et mes enfants
"pour ma retraite."
En général,
ça se passe pas comme ça.
-Le discours de La Baule
de François Mitterrand,
pour ce qui concernait
l'Afrique de l'Ouest,
sous influence,
entre guillemets, française,
qui appelait, justement,
à la démocratie,
"sinon vous n'aurez pas notre aide",
ça n'a pas été très loin,
cette expérience-là.
-Non, ça n'a pas été
très loin.
La plupart des pays
qui avaient...
Il y a eu
des conférences nationales
dans tous ces pays.
-On se souvient :
au Bénin, un peu partout.
-Au Bénin, au Congo,
un petit peu partout,
il y a eu
des conférences nationales
qui, en général,
se sont pas très bien passées.
Les partis uniques
qu'il y avait avant
avaient un seul mérite :
c'était une chappe de plomb
qui étouffait
les tensions intercommunautaires.
Les conférences nationales
ont permis
à ces tensions intercommunautaires
de s'exprimer
de manière
souvent conflictuelle
sous le couvert de partis
qui, en général, étaient
des partis régionaux,
des partis communautaristes.
Donc cette expérience-là
de démocratie,
née après La Baule,
a souvent sombré,
dans le capharnaum,
ou, parfois,
dans des guerres civiles
comme on a vu
au Congo-Brazzaville ou ailleurs.
-François Soudan, vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction
d'un magazine
qui s'appelle Jeune Afrique,
magazine panafricain.
Vous êtes dans ce journal
depuis fort longtemps,
en 1977, si vous me permettez
de le rappeler.
Donc vous avez une expérience
nullement comparable
sur la couverture...
Comment on travaille
sur un continent
où la démocratie,
c'est pas simple,
où les pressions sont fortes
de la part d'anciennes
puissances coloniales
et des partis politiques
sur place ?
C'est difficile
d'être un journal panafricain,
dans un tel contexte.
-Vous dites "depuis 1977".
J'appartiens à une espèce
en voie de disparition.
-Non, c'est pas...
-Vous avez raison.
-C'est pour montrer
votre expérience.
-Dans le même journal
depuis 77,
il n'y en a pas beaucoup
qui sont restés aussi longtemps.
Vous savez pourquoi il est établi
à Paris, d'ailleurs ?
-Il a été fondé par un Tunisien.
-BECHIR BEN YAHMED.
-Un très grand journaliste,
un très grand patron de presse.
-Il nous a quittés
il n'y a pas longtemps.
-En 2021, en mai 2021.
A qui je dois beaucoup.
-Et qui a fondé
son journal,
au moment des indépendances.
-Oui, mais ce journal
s'est très vite installé à Paris,
car on était à l'époque
de la guerre d'Algérie.
Il était, à l'époque, à Tunis.
Ensuite, il est allé à Rome.
A la fin de la guerre d'Algérie,
il s'est installé à Paris.
Pourquoi on est restés
à Paris
et on ne s'est pas installés
en Afrique ?
Il n'y avait pas de liberté
nulle part.
C'est le seul endroit
à partir duquel on pouvait
écrire, travailler
et dire ce que l'on voulait.
Donc on a connu
toute une période
d'interdictions, de saisies, etc.,
qui était...
-Quand vous déplaisiez,
vous étiez retiré du marché.
-On était retiré du marché,
on était interdit,
on ne pouvait plus rentrer,
ou alors saisi aux numéros.
On prenait tous les numéros.
La police achetait
les numéros qui débarquaient.
Ils mettaient le feu
ou en faisaient
ce qu'ils voulaient.
On a connu
des périodes comme ça
dans beaucoup de pays,
d'interdictions très dures,
au Maroc, en Algérie.
L'Algérie, ça a duré longtemps.
Dans des pays très dictatoriaux,
comme la Guinée de Sékou Touré,
le Zaïre de Mobutu,
des périodes difficiles.
-Vous essayiez
de faire votre métier,
ça déplaisait.
-Et ça déplaisait.
Ca déplaisait.
-C'est encore le cas ?
-Le chef d'Etat décidait
de nous saisir
ou de nous interdire.
C'est moins le cas.
Le développement du numérique,
on ne peut plus faire grand-chose.
Donc la censure est
beaucoup moins forte,
mais là, on a
de grosses difficultés
pour travailler au Mali.
C'est très difficile.
-Il y a eu plusieurs coups d'Etat
il y a peu.
-Il y a une junte militaire
maintenant au pouvoir,
qui est très antifrançaise,
bien que nous ne soyons pas
un journal français,
mais un journal en français,
édité à partir de Paris.
Donc ils nous mêlent
à tout ça.
Nos envoyés spéciaux
sont toujours expulsés.
C'est très compliqué.
-Vous souffrez
de ce sentiment antifrançais
qui, aujourd'hui, s'installe
un peu partout
en Afrique francophone,
alors qu'il y a
des causes très différentes ?
Ces causes ne sont pas
uniquement,
contrairement à ce qu'on dit,
dues à la difficulté
de l'armée française
à faire le ménage au Sahel.
Il y a d'autres causes,
plus profondes.
-Les causes préexistaient.
Ca a démarré avec le franc CFA,
c'est pas nouveau.
-La monnaie commune à ces pays-là.
-Voilà. La France a payé,
il faut le reconnaître,
la manière
dont elle a décolonisé.
On ne parle pas
de sentiment antibritannique
sur le continent africain.
-Toute l'Afrique de l'Est.
-Ils ont colonisé
la moitié du continent.
Pas de sentiment antiportugais
en Angola ou au Mozambique.
Il y a un sentiment antifrançais
sans doute car on a mal réussi
à s'éloigner
au moment où il le fallait,
sans doute
parce qu'on a fait preuve
de trop d'ingérence
et trop d'arrogance.
Ingérence, arrogance.
-Expliquez ces deux mots.
-Ca a été le cas
pour la France
dans la période qu'on a appelée
la "Françafrique",
qui n'existe plus.
-Elle n'existe plus ?
-Non, je ne pense pas.
On est vraiment
au bout de la queue de comète,
mais il n'y a plus la Françafrique
telle qu'on l'a connue,
telle que l'a définie
Houphouët-Boigny, à l'époque.
Il a créé le mot.
-Le président ivoirien.
-C'était l'époque de Gaulle,
Pompidou, Giscard,
Foccart, évidemment,
Jacques Foccart.
-La colonne vertébrale
de ce système.
-Voilà, du système.
Ca a continué ensuite un peu
sous Jacques Chirac.
Déjà, il commençait
à y avoir un éloignement.
Puis, sous Sarkozy,
Hollande
et maintenant Macron,
on s'en est, je pense,
très nettement éloignés,
mais le ressentiment
existe toujours
parce qu'on a mal liquidé
cette période
des indépendances.
-Pourquoi ?
-Il fallait partir
beaucoup plus vite.
La colonisation française
était une colonisation directe.
La colonisation anglaise
était indirecte.
On se servait
des chefferies locales
qui gouvernaient
à la place du colonisateur.
-Ils ne contestaient pas
le pouvoir local.
-Nous, c'est direct :
nos ancêtres les Gaulois
dans les écoles.
C'était un sentiment...
-Une colonisation civilisatrice.
-Oui, d'acculturation.
Tout ça revient ensuite,
et tout ce passé
qui n'a pas été expliqué,
qui a mal été digéré,
c'est tout cela qui revient
comme des remugles.
C'est pas ça qui explique
la mobilisation antifrançaise
dans la rue, parce que...
Il y a eu le Mali,
il y a eu l'opération Serval,
qui a été une réussite,
au début,
et ensuite...
Je dirais pas un échec...
En tout cas,
on tournait en rond.
L'opération Barkhane
tournait en rond.
Il y a eu, après,
la propagande russe qui est arrivée.
C'est cette propagande-là
qui a donné, je dirais,
un axe assez précis
à ce sentiment antifrançais,
qui l'a alimenté
de manière assez inquiétante
pour les Français.
-Elle est en péril,
l'influence française,
à votre avis ?
-Dans une certaine mesure, oui.
Il faut que la France arrive
à repenser ses relations
avec l'Afrique
de manière plus professionnelle,
de manière moins sentimentale.
Il faut être professionnel.
Il faut... enlever
tout cet aspect affectif
dans les relations.
Les Africains ne veulent plus
de cet aspect affectif.
Ils n'en veulent plus.
Il faut qu'Emmanuel Macron
fasse très attention.
Il ne peut pas s'empêcher
de mettre cet affect parfois
sur la table.
Il peut pas s'empêcher...
Quand il était à Ouagadougou,
il l'a fait.
-Le discours de 2017.
Il était au pouvoir
depuis peu de temps.
Il va à Ouagadougou,
il parle du Burkina Faso.
-Ce qui gâche tout,
c'est quand il dit
au président Kaboré
qu'il est parti rallumer la clim.
-C'est ça.
Il y a le président Kaboré,
qui est le président,
à l'époque,
du Burkina.
Il se lève
parce qu'un propos de Macron
lui déplaît un petit peu.
Macron lance ça
en disant :
"Il est parti allumer
la climatisation."
Il s'exprime
devant des étudiants, en plus,
à l'époque.
Il promet monts et merveilles.
-Il promet énormément de choses.
Sur les visas, etc.
Il promet beaucoup de choses,
qui ont pas été suivies d'effet.
On a essayé de rattraper le coup
avec le sommet de Montpellier.
-Là, c'était
avec la société civile.
-Uniquement
Le problème,
c'est que c'est avec une élite
dirigée par des gens très bien,
coordonnée par des gens très bien
comme Achille Mbembe,
comme Felwine Sarr, etc.
Ce sont des intellectuels
que l'on met ici en valeur, etc.,
mais qui sont des gens
qui sont écoutés
par une infime fraction
de la population africaine,
alors que les Russes,
si je puis dire,
ou le sentiment antifrançais
utilisé par les Russes
met en première ligne
des influenceurs
qui, eux, tapent
en dessous de la ceinture
et donc parlent directement
aux gens de la rue.
-Ca passe par les réseaux sociaux.
-Il y a beaucoup d'insultes,
il y a des fake news.
Ca fait appel à un certain nombre
de sentiments xénophobes, etc.
Donc, ça fonctionne
beaucoup mieux
et ça mobilise des centaines
de milliers de personnes.
Face à cela,
la France fait quoi ?
Elle essaye de contre-attaquer
au niveau des réseaux sociaux,
mais les Français ne peuvent pas
utiliser les mêmes armes.
La désinformation,
c'est pas possible.
Donc, c'est
une guerre asymétrique.
-Oui, d'accord.
-Les Russes,
qui ont fait de l'Afrique
un second front,
après celui de l'Ukraine...
Il suffit de voir
le vote à l'ONU et les tournées
de monsieur Lavrov.
A Bamako, il propose
l'aide sécuritaire de la Russie
non seulement au Mali,
où elle existe déjà,
en Centrafrique aussi,
mais aussi au Burkina Faso,
à la Guinée,
à tous les pays menacés,
en disant qu'ils sont prêts
à les aider.
Difficile pour la France.
C'est une période compliquée.
-Vous avez interviewé
quasiment toute la planète,
tous les chefs d'Etat
et de gouvernement
de la planète africaine,
de l'Afrique.
Quels sont ceux
qui vous ont le plus
impressionné ou marqué,
ce qui est pas tout à fait
la même chose, d'ailleurs ?
-Bonne question.
Au niveau
de l'agilité intellectuelle
et de la très grande difficulté
à le faire parler,
à le contredire,
c'est Paul Kagame,
incontestablement.
-Le président rwandais actuel.
-J'ai fait un livre
et une interview avec lui.
Il est à la fois très intéressant
et très difficile à piéger.
C'est un personnage
d'une agilité intellectuelle
assez remarquable
et assez redoutable.
J'avais de bonnes interviews
avec Idriss Déby père.
-Qui est donc
le président du Tchad.
-Qui est mort au combat.
Son fils lui a succédé.
-Oui.
-Hassan II, du Maroc.
-Hassan II, oui.
-C'est un personnage...
-Grande intelligence.
Très grande culture.
-Très grande connaissance
de la France.
Un personnage
d'une acuité absolument remarquable.
-Oui.
-Je l'ai interviewé une fois
et j'avoue
que j'en suis pas sorti indemne
parce que c'est un personnage
qui connaît la culture française
de manière extrêmement intime.
-Oui.
-Il y en a beaucoup d'autres.
Je vais pas non plus faire de...
-Il y en a un dont je veux
que vous me parliez, c'est Kadhafi.
Sa chute a quand même
pas mal chamboulé l'équilibre,
les équilibres intérieurs
à l'Afrique.
-Oui, énormément.
En tout cas, sa chute,
le fait qu'il y ait pas eu
de service après-vente, ensuite...
-Pas de remplaçant...
-Les Occidentaux se sont retirés
après l'avoir fait tomber.
-C'est une faute, ça ?
-C'est une faute très grave
qui est directement à l'origine
de l'instabilité actuelle au Sahel.
-C'est ça.
-La Libye était
une armurerie à ciel ouvert
après Kadhafi.
Tout le monde s'est servi,
avec des centaines
de milliers d'armes.
Toutes ces armes...
-Elles venaient d'où, ces armes ?
-Des stocks de Kadhafi.
Kadhafi a acheté des armes
par millions de tonnes.
Il a fait ça pendant 30 ans.
Donc, c'était...
Voilà, il avait
des arsenaux énormes,
qui ont tous été pillés
et qui ont tous servi ensuite
aux terroristes, aux djihadistes,
aux narcotrafiquants.
Tous les gens,
tous ces groupes
qui se baladent actuellement
à travers le Sahel,
du Mali jusqu'à la Somalie,
l'armement, pour beaucoup,
vient des stocks libyens
qui ont été pillés intégralement,
à cette époque.
-On dit beaucoup
que la chute de Kadhafi
a provoqué une espèce
de no man's land, la Libye,
parce que la Libye
n'a jamais vraiment été un Etat.
C'était un territoire
tenu par un homme...
-Oui, défini par ses frontières,
c'est tout.
-C'est ça.
Ca, ça a complètement bouleversé,
je dirais,
et mis gravement en péril,
d'une certaine façon,
les intérêts français.
C'est la France qui a provoqué,
avec les Britanniques,
la chute de Kadhafi.
Finalement, les intérêts français
au Sahel ont été affectés par ça.
-Oui, oui.
Tout à fait.
Kadhafi est un personnage...
Nous n'avons pas compris
à quel point
son pouvoir reposait
sur un pouvoir
de tribu.
Donc, c'était un Etat tribal,
avec des alliances entre tribus,
avec un fioul
qui était l'argent entre eux.
On s'en est rendu compte.
On connaît la politique française
vis-à-vis de Kadhafi.
On connaît.
On lui a vendu des armes,
on l'a reçu ici...
-Vous avez un nom
qui est trompeur
parce que vous vous appelez
François Soudan,
qui est le nom
d'un des Etats de l'Afrique
- il y a aussi le Soudan du Sud -,
mais vous êtes français.
Pourquoi cet attachement
à l'Afrique ?
-Le nom est d'origine belge,
de Wallonie.
Ah, moi, je suis français...
-Vous êtes du nord, d'ailleurs.
-Du nord.
-Du nord de la France.
Pourquoi cet attachement
à l'Afrique ?
-C'est un petit peu un hasard.
J'ai fait mon service militaire
à la Coopération.
Vous avez connu ça.
-La Coopération militaire, oui.
-Coopération tout court,
pas militaire.
J'étais enseignant.
-Vous étiez enseignant.
-J'étais enseignant.
Donc, j'ai été enseignant
dans ce qui s'appelait le Dahomey.
Maintenant, c'est le Bénin.
C'est à ce moment-là
qu'est venu mon intérêt
pour le continent,
que j'ai continué ensuite
à suivre assidûment
quand j'étais à l'école
de journalisme de Lille.
A Sciences Po, j'ai continué
à travailler sur l'Afrique.
Puis, à la fin, j'ai postulé
à différents emplois.
Le premier à répondre
a été Béchir Ben Yahmed.
-A Jeune Afrique.
-Je suis arrivé à Jeune Afrique.
-Vous êtes resté.
Du coup,
cet amour de l'Afrique
parce que j'imagine qu'il y a
un amour derrière ça, quand même,
c'est pas uniquement politique.
C'est aussi culturel ?
-Bah, je suis...
Oui, c'est culturel aussi.
Mon épouse est africaine.
-D'accord.
-Elle est congolaise.
Elle est ministre
dans le gouvernement
de Denis Sassou-Nguesso.
Elle est ministre
de l'Environnement,
ce qui d'ailleurs...
A Jeune Afrique,
j'ai décidé
de ne plus écrire
sur le Congo.
-Le Congo-Brazzaville.
D'accord.
-L'attachement est
forcément culturel
puisque mes enfants ont
la double nationalité.
-Vous avez un livre
de littérature africaine
que vous appréciez
tout particulièrement ?
-Les livres d'Ahmadou Kourouma.
-"Allah n'est pas obligé".
-"En attendant le vote
des bêtes sauvages".
Moi qui ai bien connu...
-C'est un écrivain ivoirien.
Malheureusement,
il est mort aujourd'hui.
-Il est décédé.
C'est un des meilleurs livres.
Le personnage qu'il décrit,
le chef d'Etat,
c'est Eyadema,
l'ancien président du Togo.
-Oui.
-Et l'un des archétypes
de la Centrafrique, qui est aussi
un personnage truculent.
J'ai bien connu Eyadema
et son pays, à l'époque.
Je l'ai retrouvé
chez Kourouma,
mais écrit de manière sublime.
-Une musique
que vous aimez
sur le continent ?
-"Indépendance Cha Cha",
ça a été...
-"Indépendance Cha Cha" ?
-Oui.
Chaque fois que j'entends ça,
je me retrouve replongé,
ou plutôt plongé,
parce que je n'ai pas connu
cette époque,
dans les années 60,
celles de tous les rêves
de l'indépendance
de l'Afrique,
celles de la création de l'UA.
-L'Union africaine.
-L'Afrique de Lumumba.
-Des gens qui étaient
pour le panafricanisme.
-Le panafricanisme,
mais dans tout ce qu'il y avait
d'humaniste derrière.
C'était pas
un panafricanisme agressif
vis-à-vis de l'Occident,
comme on a actuellement.
-C'est quoi,
le panafricanisme ?
-Le panafricanisme...
-De cette époque.
-C'est une idée qui vient,
pour beaucoup,
de Marcus Garvey,
des Américains,
des Noirs américains
de l'époque,
qui préconisaient le retour
au continent, à la racine, etc.,
une Afrique unie,
une Afrique sans frontières,
puisque les frontières
ont été définies
à la conférence de Berlin
par le colonisateur.
-En 1885.
-Voilà.
Donc, une Afrique unie
qui ne forme
qu'un seul et même pays.
On a eu le même rêve,
à un moment, avec l'Europe.
-Mais aujourd'hui,
ce panafricanisme,
ça veut pas dire
tout à fait la même chose.
-C'est un argument de combat
intellectuel, culturel,
de revendication souverainiste,
qui est...
-Anti-européen aussi.
Anti-occidental.
-Parfois dévoyé
de manière anti-occidentale.
C'est pas uniquement antifrançais.
C'est anti-ONU, etc.
-Ca vous fait peur ?
-Je pense que c'est
une très mauvaise voie,
une très mauvaise orientation.
C'est une voie de repli sur soi
du continent.
On est en pleine mondialisation.
Personne n'y échappe.
Il y a des choses
négatives et positives.
Il faut se battre
pour que l'Afrique soit ancrée
dans la mondialisation.
A Jeune Afrique,
on a eu un premier combat
pour les indépendances
des colonisations.
Le deuxième combat,
c'était pour la fin
des partis uniques.
Le troisième, c'était
l'indépendance économique.
Le quatrième combat,
c'est pour ancrer l'Afrique
dans la mondialisation.
Le panafricanisme de combat
va à l'encontre de ça.
-Vous êtes optimiste
pour ce continent ?
-Oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr.
Il y a une forme de résilience
extraordinaire en Afrique
et une forme de créativité.
Puis, il n'y a pas que l'Afrique...
La carte de la crise de l'Afrique
est trompeuse.
Il y a toute une partie
de l'Afrique...
Il y a 54 Afriques, en fait.
Elles fonctionnent très bien.
-Merci, François Soudan.
-Merci, Yves.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...